i come for the bears for the chicago sun
times up here
i'm curious you don't strike me as a guy
who who needs any added motivation but
is there any facing the bears and also
can you appreciate why this is an
important storyline uh for other teams
who have watched their team uh
uh not draft you or pass on you
no it's no motivation um
you know that's
what the organization went with you know
i had
no ties nothing against the chicago
bands or the organization i mean of
course you know
the media is gonna make stories and like
you said you know for those fans they're
gonna of course say something about it
but you know for me personally yes no
motivation and
nothing like that you know they did what
they did and um
and just keep pushing forward
desean watson facing the chicago bears
this weekend of course the bears
taking mitchell trubisky trading up a
spot to take mitchell trubisky and
passing on both patrick holmes and
deshawn watson as several other teams
did
and now they'd surely love to have
mahomes or watson anyone but trubisky
but it could be i i don't know who's
playing this weekend for the bears i
don't think anybody cares at this point
but i think it's your business top
match-up
top match-ups for week 14. chris you've
got the trivia question for me okey
dokey your favorite quarterback
your favorite quarterback mike florio of
your favorite team kirk cousins has nine
tds over the last three weeks
second most of any qb in that span what
nfc qb has more than him
oh boy that's a good question that means
i'm buying tom it's got to be oh aaron
rodgers of course it is
oh thy great one striketh again
yup there you go
okay was that specifically picked by you
just so you know keep some more praise
on it i i've not you know i'm not and i
don't i haven't been heaping that much
praise think about how many times this
year you've got on me because i haven't
praised him enough so
i will say this i don't understand why
he
in the sports books points bet whatever
is such a far second behind patrick
mahomes and the mvp i don't understand
that i i really don't to me it should be
rogers leading mahomes by just a hair in
the mvp race that's just the way i see
it sorry go ahead i think if the packers
end up with the number one seed and the
chiefs don't that's going to make for a
tough vote because i still think there's
something to be said for the quarterback
of the one seed getting extra
consideration but but you know and each
week
the odds are getting
smaller better yeah they're getting
smaller for mahomes and for rogers yeah
and they're they're separating from the
rest and of course your boy blue has now
leapfrogged russell wilson into the
third spot but but there's still a big
gap between
mahomes rogers and the rest of the field
all right first one for me boy i didn't
want the first pick there's alright i'll
take it fine go ahead no no i'm taking
it okay i'm taking it uh let me go to
tonight belichick and mcveigh super bowl
53 rematch um belichick cracked the code
on that offense two years ago held it to
three points
and and i don't care what mcvay or jared
goff or anyone else says they're gonna
be thinking about what happened on that
day in atlanta less than two years ago
it really wasn't that long ago in the
grand scheme of things even though the
world has changed dramatically since
that day in early 2019 i i think that
that the chess match
that happens tonight is going to be one
of the most fascinating of the weekend
if not the year yeah i'm with you i
think it is it's cool because i mean we
know both these guys smart as hell right
evil genius first kid genius all that i
mean that's awesome but um
two i think like you know what we talked
about a little earlier the fact that
mcveigh's played two patriots assistants
already you know in the giants and the
dolphins
you know who does that help you know who
does that help does that help
you know mcveigh to go wait this is what
this coaching regime is doing to me so
now i got to be ready to do this
or does it help you know belichick and
go okay i saw what they did and now i'll
just have a few things i do differently
i think that is it's a good pick it was
one i was thinking about with my person
let me ask you a question yeah let me
ask you a question because we hear from
time to time how coaches will coordinate
kind of off the record off the books
to to assist each other based upon the
fact that they've played someone
could you see
i don't think the patriots are enough of
a threat to the dolphins right now but
maybe they are could you see flores kind
of kind of sharing with mcveigh
what he thinks belichick will do or has
done or what to watch out for i can't
imagine i don't think so double agent
opening right no i don't and i think the
the real reason would be because i'm
sure brian flores would like to just
stick to the patriots and go here you go
but he'd be giving the tricks within his
own defense away too right i think
that's ultimately why he would not want
to do that or coaches don't do that so
you're right yeah he's going to face
mcveigh again at some point right so he
goes i don't want him to know like hey
when you were in this formation i and
belichick were thinking this and that's
why we kept stopping you or whatever
yeah that would just be my first thought
um all right i'm gonna go to our game
sunday night my boy blue
versus blitzburg yeah that match up i
mean i'm i'm excited i mean josh allen
has entered you know superstar
stratosphere i can take over a game at a
given point i don't care what your
defense is and all of that pittsburgh
has not played a
quarterback or an offense like this all
year long this will by far be their
biggest test they've had to face and
there's a lot of problems that like josh
allen and company present so you know i
know it's not a one-on-one matchup here
but can their pass rush contain josh
allen hey that 49ers pass rush is pretty
good they couldn't contain them the
other night and then can pittsburgh
cover
you know the buffalo bills pittsburgh
wants to play zone coverage the 49ers
played zone coverage he picked it apart
then they got oh we have to play man
even though we don't like to play man
and he picked it apart so that to me is
going to be a very interesting matchup
what pittsburgh can do to keep him off
kilter can they pressure him and contain
him and do all that
i'm excited to watch that on on our
channel sunday night
yeah that should be a great great game
and it's it's one of the great remaining
games of the regular season as we
pointed out in yesterday's draft all
right next one for me
and we already talked about brian flores
and this is a sneaky great game between
the chiefs and the dolphins on sunday
brian flores versus the chief's passing
game because chris and i was reminded of
this yesterday it was that afc
championship game a couple of years ago
when flores was still working for the
patriots where they came up with a way
to neutralize tyreek hill the man
coverage underneath the the the single
high safety who presumably was covering
anyone and everyone but was doubling
hill right what are they going to do how
do they pick their poisons here travis
kelsey's having a great year tyree kill
is still tyree kill they've got other
weapons at their disposal in the kansas
city chief passing game what will the
dolphins do and how will bryan flores
deploy his guys
to to try to take away a tyree kill or
slow down a travis kelsey that's the
thing if you lean too far
to stop one guy you open things up for
the other guy it's gonna be
very interesting to see what flores does
as the guy who's running the show right
not the guy who's working for the guy
who runs the show yeah this is why i'm
mad you got the first pick because i
wanted that pick i wanted that right
there i wasn't gonna quite have done it
and well you did have a pic before mine
well i know but i did then i might have
lost blue to the blitzberg defense too i
had to make a choice there so i went
with that one um but i i mean you're
right i was going to use more of the
angle of the the dolphin secondary
versus the chief's wide receivers but
because of all the same thoughts you
talked about and the dolphins are one of
the few teams and all of football
that can kind of match up with the
receivers
that's hey xavier howard and byron jones
it really doesn't get much better than
those two as far as a combo you know
they still got the rookie first round
who they drafted who i can't say his
last name out of auburn he plays well
they got good secondary guys i mean
this is going to be interesting i mean i
i think that game will be close i think
i would be shocked if the chiefs blew
them out i don't know we'll see and
flores is sandbagging a little bit he
said yesterday he'd like to have 14
players on defense i i think i think
he's trying
to get the chiefs to sleepwalk a little
bit make them think that it's going to
be easy yeah it's the jedi mind trick i
don't think it's gonna work but uh right
he doesn't need 14. he's good enough to
get it done with 11. yeah well yeah he's
uh he's using like uh you know like
belichick is doing tonight where there
are 70 guys on the questionable roster
it's like a little little subtle
subtle mind trick there um all right
since you stole my damn pick i'm all
flustered now i think i'm going to go to
the browns browns ravens game though and
specifically
the browns o line versus raven's d-line
i mean this game is going to be one in
the trenches we know that both these
teams want to run the football and you
really you know can't depend on the
passing game you know to win you the
football game we're seeing baker and
cleveland are obviously better in the
passing game but i mean hey
one thing
i'm mad we didn't talk about more
yesterday with the ravens you know just
why we're on it here is just the ravens
pass game is is concerning i don't care
what they did to dallas the other night
it's unbelievable how average it is
there's just nothing there i sit and
watch on film on tv whatever there's no
people up and there's no great design uh
but
i i still i have more confidence i guess
at the base level to just say i think
the ravens
can run on cleveland i do because
cleveland's run defense is not that
great all of those things
i i i
i think cleveland can run on the ravens
d line
i think ravensd line has shown that they
can be pushed around here the last few
weeks so it's a little concerning but
i'm not sure glass campbell hey at least
he's back healthy maybe they're going to
be a little bit better this game but to
me that's the matchup that determines
the game if cleveland can run the ball
on baltimore they're going to win uh i i
feel confident of that but if it's like
hey nick chubb's got 60 yards and kareem
hunt's only got like 40 yards and
something like that then baltimore is
gonna win the football game
all right the next one for me and
there's a few i can choose from but you
know what from the standpoint of
overall intrigue and excitement
jamal adams versus the jets anyone from
the jets anyone who gets close to him in
a jets uniform any jets coach any person
representing directly or indirectly the
new york jets organization
because we know how fiery and emotional
jamal adams is he's been waiting for
this one from the moment he got what he
wanted his trade out of new york my only
regret is le'veon bell isn't still on
the jets because they went back and
forth about their meeting coming up in
mid-december but yeah i want to see
everything jamal adams does when he
interacts with anyone from the jets
chris yeah i i agree i mean i would
think he's gonna be volatile and
you know very passionate and in their
face
and talking crap especially if they get
a lead it could add to the intensity and
the the chippiness of this football game
you know all together so uh i'm with you
there that'll be a pretty good one that
was one i had written down it's probably
going to be the one i was going to take
next
now
i'm going to go to kyler versus kyler
versus the giants d-line i you know just
hey the way the giants d-line played
last week and containing russell wilson
their defensive attack on that side of
the ball you know i feel like we've
talked about this with like four
different matchups today again but the
new england coaching staff versus
scrambling quarterback and all that and
at the very base level where i take it
more than just kyler cliff kingsbury's
offense needs more it needs more it's
too simple people have figured it out
and if you can just contain
kyla murray you got a chance to win the
football game and kyla murray yeah he's
being contained and then he's not
throwing the ball real well either mike
right lately he's just not he's off his
game so
his shoulder's messed up yeah he must
he's fine the shoulder is messed up he
must be he's got to get it going though
if they want any chance to win this game
coming out here in the east coast in a
cold weather game
or get to the playoffs this one and i
think they are done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports